bonjour à tous vous allez poursuivre
dans un instant en direct la séance de
questions cribles alors les questions
créé vous le savez ce sont ces questions
très précises que posent les sénateurs
un ministre le thème aujourd'hui c'est
le déficit démocratique de l'union
européenne et le ministre c'est thierry
repentin ministre délégué aux affaires
européennes
on se retrouve petit après à monsieur
titre here pantin ministre chargé des
affaires européennes sur le thème
déficit démocratique de l'union
européenne ce thème était choisi par le
groupe
udi us et je vous rappelle que l'auteur
de la question ainsi que le ministre
pour sa réponse dispose que de deux
minutes une minute au maximum peut être
présentée par pour la réponse présenté
par l'auteur de la question pour la
première question
la parole est à monsieur jean claude
requier pour le groupe rdse
monsieur le président à monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues depuis
plusieurs mois des ukrainiens se
révoltent parce que leurs dirigeants ont
soudainement tourné le dos à l'europe a
dit mieux réglementer vers le sud ce
sont des migrants du continent africain
qui continuent d'affluer au péril de
leur vie sur l'île beddouza laporte
méditerranéens de l'union européenne le
contraste est saisissant entre ceux qui
rêvent de l'europe l'espace de leurs
espoirs et ceux qui vivent mais qui ne
perçoivent plus ni pires ni idéal
européen
une récente étude dresse un constat sans
appel
70 % des français sont prêts à limiter
les bourgs de l'europe
et que dire les sondages qui placent les
extrêmes en tête des prochaines
élections européennes dans les urnes
l'union européenne est devenue triste
des fours pas des votes protestataires
le réceptacle de toutes les
contestations
nous ne pouvons pas laisser perdurer ce
sentiment de défiance l'europe atteint
un niveau de déficit démocratique qui a
mis en danger
or là c'est le champion européen c'est
d'abord redonner souffle et l'idéal
démocratique soit être une priorité
et comment ne pas évoquer le monde
actuel
six nations de long pesant au parlement
européen le découpage artificiel lui
région ne m'a pas tenu ses promesses et
loin s'en faut c'est un fiasco
le taux d'abstention augmente à chaque
scrutin et la folle désormais 50
pourtant mais surtout le plus grave
c'est le délitement croissant du lien
entre parlementaires européens et
citoyens y at il encore un rang très
rares sont les français qui connaissent
le nom d'un député européen quand vous
vous savez monsieur le ministre les
radicaux souhaitent le rétablissement
d'une circonscription unique
ils ne sont pas les seuls puisque notre
proposition de loi a été largement
adopté par le sénat en 2010 à eux
soutiennent les groupes socialistes
c'est assez réussi
alors monsieur le ministre pour combler
le déficit démocratique de l'europe et
des institutions
ne faut-il pas d'abord commencer par
renforcer le lien entre citoyens et
leurs représentants à bruxelles et à
strasbourg
comment les rendre plus visible plus
légitime plus représentatif et donc
aussi plus fort face à commission et
plus encore face à quelques notre
structure européenne qui fait tant de
ravages
merci pour répondre que tirer sont en
train ministre chargé des affaires
européennes
le président monsieur le sénateur je
connais l'attachement viscéral de votre
famille de pensée politique et les
radicaux à l'idée d'une circonscription
unique pour les actions européennes et
je le respecte bien évidemment nous
avons d'ailleurs expérimenté en france
deux boîtes de scrutin sur les élections
européennes une circonscription unique
de 79 à 2003 je m'en souviens bien j'ai
moi même été candidat sur une liste
unique et depuis des regroupements inter
régionaux qui font des grandes régions
malheureusement il faut bien reconnaître
qu'aucune des deux formules n'a permis
d'enrayer la désaffection à laquelle
veut faisait référence de nos
concitoyens à l'égard du scrutin
européen
et on arrive à un curieux paradoxe
l'abstention elle augmente au fur et à
mesure que les pouvoirs du parlement
européen à s'accroissent et ce mal ne
touche pas seulement la france elle est
partout dans beaucoup de pays de l'union
c'est donc
bien ou ailleurs que dans le mode de
scrutin qu'il faut trouver les raisons
être député européen si vous y avez fait
référence n'est pas une fonction facile
influence au parlement européen ne se
décrète pas elle s'acquiert par une
présence forte sur les dossiers par une
capacité à négocier avec les élus des
pays différentes différentes cultures de
sensibilités politiques différentes et
il en est de même d'ailleurs fabuleux
débat européen dans nos régions
quant à la complexité du système
décisionnel européen
elle est réelle mais n'exagérons pas
l'europe est finalement aux états ce que
l'intercommunalité est aux communes nous
avons en partage une maison commis ces
règles du jeu qui permet de construire
des compromis de faire émerger un
intérêt général tout en respectant
chacune et chacun de ces cons nantes
c'est pas une histoire de meccano
institutionnel qui fera redonner
confiance dans l'europe ce qui leur
donne confiance dans leur pub c'est des
petites peines qui réponde aux
aspirations des concitoyens des mesures
ambitieuses union européenne plus
intégré plus solidaire plus prospère
plus juste ce que nous employons de fer
avec l'impulsion du président d'avic et
c'est sans doute cette image qui fait
qu'effectivement des milliers de gens à
kiev
nothalten manifeste pour nous rejoindre
un jour
merci monsieur jean claude rouiller j'ai
participé à de nombreuses inaugurations
comme élu j'ai rencontré beaucoup d'élus
d'opposition euros de mer de conduire et
jaune ont deux députés des sénateurs
beaucoup de présidents sous préfet hélas
très peu de députés européens même capte
l'europe apporté des fortes
contributions alors j'ai fait que le lot
comme l'ariège et le ring de bruxelles
ou à strasbourg
même si en l'autre devient comme un
effort qui est le dernier survivant du
cd du traité de désigner signataire du
traité de rome
je dois demeurer simplement aux futurs
députés européens qu'on les voit un peu
plus sur le terrain quand les rencontres
et puis à celle qui incarne l'europe
et puis qui donnait enfin un peu plus de
coeur et de passion à l'idée européenne
qui y voit une belle idée merci la
parole est à notre collègue jean bise
pour le groupe ump merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues
pardonnez ma formule familière mais la
question du déficit démocratique de
l'union européenne c'est un peu la
question du verre à moitié vide ou à
moitié plein j'ai tendance à le voir à
moitié plein en effet depuis le traité
de lisbonne et parlements nationaux sont
mieux intégrés au processus de décision
européen et le parlement européen a
considérablement renforcé ses pouvoirs
il n'est qu'à voir son rôle affirmé lors
de la renégociation et du vote sur le
budget 2014-2020 le traité sur la
stabilité le tcg
lui aussi va dans le même sens en créant
procédure d'information participation
des parlements nationaux par le biais de
la conférence interparlementaire sur le
gouvernance économique nous avons sont
progressivement et si les crises
économiques et financières ont constitué
ont constitué autant de chocs pour les
institutions européennes le
fonctionnement de l'union a globalement
progressé de façon positive même si
parfois l'intergouvernemental a primé
sur le communautaire mais les
gouvernements sont aussi issus des urnes
et dans l'urgence est bien le
l'intergouvernemental était à mon avis
beaucoup plus pertinent aujourd'hui nous
estimons qu'il y a une marge d'action
pour améliorer le fonctionnement
institutionnel de l'union le chemin peut
paraître complexe il déroute parfois nos
concitoyens nous devons faire preuve de
dégoût magot gît encore et toujours
surtout en ce moment
et parallèlement nous donnons vont pas
abandonner le projet européen
dans cette perspective monsieur le
ministre nous sommes très attentifs aux
éclaircissements que vous pourriez nous
donner des propos du prix de la
république pour un vrai gouvernement de
la zone euro
quel est son contenu exact et
implique-t-il un miroir dans un
parlement en de la zone euro merci
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
oui monsieur le sénateur au bizet
l'union européenne comme vous le savez
comprend effectivement 28 membres nous
souhaitons avancer à 28 mai 18
on souhaitait avoir une même monnaie et
forme d'une certaine manière le coeur du
réacteur de l'union européenne
approfondir de l'union économique et
monétaire dans ce cadre là est
essentielle pour en assurer la stabilité
et faire en sorte qu'ils constituent un
moteur positif pour tous soit vous dire
que notre priorité aujourd'hui et je
sais que vous y êtes attentif c'est
l'union bancaire avec ses deux piliers à
la fois la supervision de l'ensemble des
banques c'est ce qu'on appelle la
supervision unique qui est en train de
se mettre en place
actuellement mais également la
résolution unique c'est à dire c'est un
certain nombre de règles du jeu qui
seront là pour trouver des solutions à
la mise en banqueroute d'une banque par
exemple et ça c'est en discussion
aujourd'hui avec le parlement européen
on doit ensuite continué à renforcer la
coordination des politiques économiques
pour assurer la fois la convergence de
nos économies et des niveaux de
croissance plus élevés et les
discussions portent aujourd'hui sur ces
fameux contrats de compétitivité et de
croissance
dans le même temps je souhaite insister
nous donnons et c'est essentiel à mes
yeux parce que c'est totalement nouveau
une dimension sociale à l'union
économique et monétaire est le président
de la république a dessiné cette
perspective d'un gouvernement donc de la
zone euro avec un objectif qui serait la
croissance et l'emploi
et avec le jour venu une capacité
financière c'est à dire un budget propre
à la zone euro qui pourrait lui donner
davantage de moyens d'action il nous
faudra donc bien sûr comme vous l'avez
souligné améliorer le contrôle
démocratique et assurer une légitimité
démocratique à l'union économique et
monétaire
il nous faudra comme vous l'avez
souligné améliorer ce contrôle
démocratique et donc dans cet esprit le
président la république et la
chancelière le 30 mai ont appelé à la
mise en place après les élections
européennes de structure dédiée est
spécifique à la zone euro
dans le nouveau parlement et nous avons
demandé au président du parlement de
réfléchir à la solution qui lui semble
la plus adaptée à cette volonté que nous
ayons quelque sorte des députés qui
effectivement soit plus investi au sein
du parlement européen sur la zone euro
nous souhaitons aussi pour cette
démocratie faire qu'il y ait plus de
dialogue entre la zone euro et les
représentants aussi des salariés et des
employeurs notamment à travers la
confédération européenne des syndicats
merci monsieur le ministre ces deux
minutes pour les questions cribles
différent des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
notre collègue jean bizet merci monsieur
le président tu es ministre j'ai pris
note avec intérêt des réponses que vous
venez de me faire je note également que
la mise en place de l'union bancaire j'y
adhère totalement même si je vois qu'une
certaines discordances dans l'ampleur de
l'analyse entre la position du
commissaire michel barnier
et puis des positions de la france je
souhaiterais une attitude beaucoup plus
je dirais coercitives en la matière
quand on sait les dégâts que nous avons
pu connaître
il y a quelques années je regrette
également la lenteur de la mise en
oeuvre même si je le sais ce n'est pas
facile de cette union bancaire et après
de l'union économique et monétaire
auquel nous devons tous aspirer et
j'avoue que j'ai entendu avec beaucoup
d'intérêt les propos de madame merkel
hier au bundestag et je souhaiterais à
nouveau également entendre la parole de
la france en la matière merci la parole
est à notre collègue chantal jouanno
pour le groupe eut des us merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues je vous remercie pour
cette séance à l'initiative de notre
groupe qui a une acuité toute
particulière puisque un récent sondage
place un parti clairement europhobe en
tête justement des prévisions de vote
aux futures élections européennes ce qui
pour notre parti pour qui la
construction européenne est presque
consubstantielle à son existence est un
signe extrêmement négatif il semblerait
que 56 ans après la signature des
traités
à une époque où l'époque des pères
fondateurs ou nos concitoyens savez
combien l'europe était la condition de
la paix aujourd'hui l'europe ne s'impose
plus
tout comme une évidence et c'est vrai
qu'il ya jamais de mots assez forts pour
critiquer l'europe dans les différents
discours sur l'euro fort sur le diktat
sur le déficit démocratique que nous
avons utilisés nous savons dans cette
danse est c'est sûr des gouvernements
qui parfois alimente aussi cette
méfiance david cameron qui veut annoncer
qu a annoncé un référendum sur l'avenir
de la participation de la
grande-bretagne à l'union des
manifestations contre la commission à
athènes à madrid à lisbonne
manifestement les espoirs sont déçus et
pourtant on oublie aussi de rappeler et
ça vient d'être discutée que beaucoup
d'initiatives très positifs sont le fait
des organes les plus fédéralistes de
l'union européenne ceux qui sont même
allés plus critiqué puisque c'est la
commission qui a initié le projet du nom
bancaire c'est la banque centrale
européenne qui a restauré la confiance
sur les marchés
aussi vous le savez mon collègue jean
arthuis regrette beaucoup ce manque de
confiance lié à ce qu'il estime être un
manque de démocratie et vous venez
d'évoquer la question de la gouvernance
économique européenne il souhaiterait
que les parlements nationaux soient
beaucoup plus impliqués dans les débats
et notamment dans les débats
préalablement aux débats du conseil qui
nous semble être un point extrêmement
important et j'ajouterais pour ma part
monsieur le ministre puisque vous êtes
exprimés sur un gouvernement de la zone
euro et que vous y êtes favorable ce qui
est une très bonne chose
jusqu'où dans le cadre de ce
gouvernement pousse auriez-vous l'idée
d'une convergence l'idée d'une véritable
politique énergétique européenne et
d'une politique des ressources en europe
je vous remercie
merci sur le ministre oui madame la
ministre
les prochaines élections européennes
constituent vous le savez une importance
majeure pour notre pays pour l'union
dans un contexte économique difficile
avec des tentations au mieux peu
d'abstention qui s'exprime au pire d'une
progression des mouvements populistes
qui prennent évidemment l'europe un bouc
émissaire de tous nos maux ce phénomène
moi je les observe dans hélas beaucoup
trop de pays de l'union et les sondages
malheureusement nous montrent que la
menace est réelle mais c'est pas une
fatalité et
nous pouvons les uns et les autres faire
notre art de pédagogie pour ma part je
le fais chaque semaine dans une région
différente de france pour répondre aux
inquiétudes montrer de manière concrète
et tangible comment l'europe et dans nos
vies quotidiennes sans que nous n'en
ayons un peu conscience et j'en tire
aussi une conclusion de ces déplacements
c'est que contrairement à ce que l'on
dit les français sont pas forcément
eurosceptique pour beaucoup ils sont
euros ignorant parce qu'on ne leur a pas
suffisamment parlé de l'europe au
quotidien au cours des dernières années
leur dire que la politique de la ville
c'est le fonds social européen leur dire
les grands aménagements qui sont faits
en france c'est le feder leur dire aussi
que le fonds d aide alimentaire aux
démunis ça permet au secours catholique
ou aux restos du coeur d'accompagner nos
concitoyens les plus déshérités c'est ça
la réalité de l'europe dans la vie
quotidienne des gens et l'occasion m'est
donnée de le rappeler ici aujourd'hui
il faut aussi redire que la priorité de
l'europe c'est l'emploi et que nous
avons par exemple au cours des derniers
mois augmenter le capital de la banque
européenne d'investissements de 10
milliards d'euros au bénéfice des pme
sur nos territoires de dire que nous
allons avoir une politique agricole
commune qui va nous permettre d'avoir
une agriculture plus juste plus proche
plus verte
et puis parce que vous m'avez posé la
question sur la dimension énergétique
vous avez totalement raison il y a un
grand rendez vous c'est le conseil de
mars prochain qui sera consacrée aux
problèmes énergétiques avec je l'espère
une grande ambition qui sera partagée
par tous les pays de l'union européenne
- 40% de d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre dans l'atmosphère
27 % d'énergies renouvelables c'est la
position que portera à la france et
j'espère qu'il permettra un débat sur
cette question là pendant les
européennes
merci madame jouanno merci merci
monsieur le ministre
espérons que vous soyez bien entendu
mieux entendus et plus entendu puisque
sur le fond on partage une vision très
fédéraliste de de l'europe et on partage
cette volonté que les gouvernements
associe beaucoup mieux aussi les
parlements parce que c'est ce
gouvernement qui négocie au conseil dans
le cadre des débats préalables au
conseil mais
très honnêtement aujourd'hui c'est une
oeuvre collective qui va falloir mener
tous les partis ici sont plutôt
convaincu par l'europe et nous nous
sommes convaincus que c'est par plus
d'europe et une europe clairement
fédéralistes que nous parviendrons à
sortir notre pays de ce faible taux de
croissance très bien je passe la parole
à notre collègue richard yung pour le
groupe socialiste le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues
j'écoutais madame jouanno en me disant
espérons que son plaidoyer fédéraliste
puisse être entendu car de nos jours
être fédéraliste
c'est tout de même porter une croix pour
ceux qui ce pont chrétien
voilà mais pour revenir au débat je
voulais intervenir sur un point plus
spécifique du déficit démocratique
c'est celui de des troïkas soit belle la
troïka la troïka vous le savez c'est une
mission composée d'un représentant de la
commission européenne d'un représentant
de la banque centrale européenne et d'un
représentant du fmi qui se rend dans les
pays en difficulté budgétaire financière
et qui lie fait une analyse la situation
et qui surtout fait des recommandations
plus que des recommandations sur les
politiques à suivre et il y a
à suivre par le pays en question il y as
autour de ce mécanisme
un débat et un certain nombre de
critiques justifiées en ce sens que les
trois quarts qui ont beaucoup de pouvoir
propose souvent des politiques qui sont
parfois contradictoires entre celles qui
sont proposées par la commission qui
vise à réduire les déficits et par le
fmi qui vise à réduire le niveau des
salaires et le niveau dépenses et qui le
fait l'objet en fait d'aucun contrôle
démocratique ou d'ailleurs même pas
démocratique par les différentes
instances européennes
il ya donc un vrai malaise par rapport à
ces assez troïka avec le fait qu'on plus
on se demande pourquoi le fmi fait
partie de la troïka
il ya déjà la commission européenne et
la bce et à tel point que vous le savez
la commission européenne a instauré un
groupe de travail sur sur cette question
donc je vois que mon temps de parole est
déjà terminée donc on verra tout à
l'heure pour le rémois eu deux ministres
alors vraiment je sais simplement quelle
est la position du gouvernement français
par rapport à l'avenir et au contrôle
des troïkas merci monsieur le ministre
oui monsieur le président le sénateur
n'a pas pu aller au bout de sa question
mais j'avais compris quel était le sens
néanmoins de son interpellation et je
crois qu'il faut effectivement revenir
précisément sur les responsabilités et
la légitimité de chacune des
institutions que vous avez cités
s'agissant de la troïka qui réunit comme
vous savez la banque centrale européenne
la commission et le fmi elle est à juste
titre l'objet quelquefois de critiques
je trouve que c'est légitime je le dis
ces programmes dette sont souvent
avérées très exigeant parfois beaucoup
trop et la troïka a beaucoup tâtonné en
élaborant des programmes dead alors que
ceux ci avaient un trail est majeur pour
les citoyens européens et nous avons
tous à l'esprit notamment la population
grecque notamment est en effet cette
troïka renvoie une image négative de
l'europe
alors où seuls s'ils doivent apparaître
comme une solution et non un problème
l'europe s'est malheureusement pas le
cas je dois rappeler quelques faits
premièrement quand même la troïka elle
élabore des programmes d'aidé en pleine
concertation avec les gouvernants qui
sont concernés
ces décisions sans suite avalisé par les
ministres des finances des gouvernements
de la zone euro qui en informe le
parlement par la suite puisque toutes
ces décisions engagent des finances
publiques de tous il n'empêche je vous
rejoins nous pouvons faire mieux et nous
le souhaitons
c'est pour cela que depuis mai 2013
un certain nombre de textes
institutionnalise justement le rôle de
la troïka tout en renforçant les
dispositifs de contrôle des programmes
qu'elle institue parfois par des
auditions parlementaires
c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle la
france l allemagne dans leur
contribution commune du 30 mai dernier
ont évoqué la possibilité de créer après
les élections européennes
des structures donc dédié à la zone euro
au sein du parlement européen afin de
garantir un contrôle démocratique et une
légitimité appropriée du processus
décisionnel européen que vous appelez de
vos voeux
merci alors mon cher collègue pour la
réplique à la réponse quelques secondes
seulement si le président je vais
surveiller les chronomètres
merci de la réponse je voulais peut-être
élargir le point auprès des collègues en
attirant votre attention sur deux
mécanismes très importants qui sont en
train d'être mise en place qui sont la
supervision bancaire européenne et la
résolution bancaire sur la suite la
supervision
il y à un contrôle et un débat organisé
par le parlement européen
mais les parlements nationaux reste en
quelque sorte à la borne est donc je
retrouve l'idée que vient d'évoquer le
ministre qu'il faut que nous ayons une
structure parlementaire de l'eurogroupe
qui puisse intervenir là et plus grave
encore dans les propositions de
résolution c'est-à-dire ceux qui
payeront et bien les parlements
nationaux sont absents or j'attire votre
attention sur le fait que pendant dix
ans c'est quand même les budgets
nationaux qui vont payer en cas de
résolution et donc il est essentiel qui
est un contrôle par le solaire national
merci je passe la parole à eric gay pour
le groupe crc et à monsieur le président
monsieur ministre chers collègues je
voudrais d'emblée salué ici l'excellente
propositions de nos collègues du groupe
u10
us et sur le choix du thème de ce débat
la très grande majorité des citoyens
européens a effectivement l'impression
que l'union européenne est une
gigantesque machine administrative très
éloignés de leurs préoccupations et ce
n'est malheureusement pas complètement
faux de plus quand la vie des peuples
est sollicité l'europe ne tient pas
toujours compte le référendum français
de 2005 en est un des exemples les plus
flagrants
le peuple a majoritairement rejeté le
traité établissant une constitution pour
l'europe ce qui n'a aucunement empêché
la ratification du traité de lisbonne
qui est sur le fond exactement le même
que celui qui fut rejetée en 2005 le
recours au référendum ne doit pas être à
géométrie variable mais être une
pratique régulière non pas que la
question de l'adhésion de la turquie qui
vient dans l'actualité ne soit pas
importante mais elle peut aussi servir à
masquer les véritables enjeux
le manque de démocratie est également
flagrant ce qui concerne les documents
et les questions budgétaires
désormais le budget présenté à bruxelles
avant même qu'ils ne soient discutés par
le parlement français
c'est quand même là un véritable déni de
la souveraineté du peuple
le dogme de la concurrence libre et non
faussée est lui aussi déjà des manières
un frein démocratique que législation
que l'on pourrait prendre pour protéger
les citoyens ou l'environnement sont
abandonnés la plupart du temps afin de
respecter le dogme sacré de cette
concurrence ce qui se traduit par un
affaiblissement du pouvoir législatif at
on demandé l'avis des citoyens européens
sur la directi les travers les tâches et
par exemple alors même que cette
dernière remet en question le droit du
travail et n'a jamais été adopté par le
parlement en français nous croyons pour
notre part à une europe des coopérations
et les souverains et des solidarités
monsieur le ministre quelles initiatives
précises le gouvernement français entend
il prendre pour rendre le processus de
la construction européenne plus
démocratique et plus proche des peuples
merci monsieur le ministre sénateur
bocquet vous avez raison il faut renouer
le lien entre les citoyens l'europe mais
c'est pas par le mécano institutionnel
que nous y parviendrons je crois que
c'est en donnant la preuve que l'europe
peut aussi apporter des réponses à la
préoccupation de nos quotidiens des
acteurs économiques des défenseurs de
l'environnement pour reprendre quelques
thématiques que vous avez
en fait c'est d'ailleurs aussi cette
démarche avec françois hollande nous
mettons en place faite de respect à la
fois pour les états membres
quel toit et les institutions qui
constant d'apporter des réponses
concrètes et c répond je vais vous en
citer quelques unes au cours des
derniers mois vous l'avez parler du
détachement des travailleurs at on pris
la tâche de nos concitoyens pas de nos
concitoyens en direct mais la tâche du
sénat français oui puisque nous avons
adopté ici ensemble à une grande
majorité une résolution européenne vous
en étiez d'ailleurs l'un des auteurs
contre le dumping social
nous avons aussi au cours des derniers
mois adopté au niveau européen une ligne
de six milliards d'euros pour aider
toutes les régions où le taux de chômage
des jeunes est trop important pour les
accompagner sur des plans de formation
développement de l'apprentissage
nous avons aujourd'hui engagé un combat
et nous irons jusqu'au bout pour lutter
par exemple contre la fraude et
l'évasion fiscale car il n'est pas
normal que nous soyons obligés
d'augmenter les impôts alors que
certains qui devraient en payer n'en
payent pas parce qu'ils passent à
travers des mailles d'un filet
institutionnel qui est trop lâche nous
avons aussi adopté un budget mille 30
milliards sur la période 2014 2020
ces mille 30 milliards seront investis
dans l'union européenne pour de grands
chantiers qui sont pourvoyeurs d'emplois
nous avons aussi aujourd'hui une
discussion pour nous assurer que dans
quelques années nous ne pourrons pas
diffuser des ogm en plein champ parce
qu'il ya des problèmes de santé et
d'environnement
ce qui veut dire que nous devons
toujours toujours là où nous sommes
avoir en tête le souci de nos
concitoyens et que pour ses mythiques
nous devons dialoguer avec les
parlements tenir compte de vos positions
comme nous avons tenu compte aussi du
carton jaune que vous avez émis ici
lorsque le droit de grève était menacée
au niveau européen nous en avons tenu
compte ce texte n'est jamais allé au
bout merci le swing bouquet et à
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie
pour votre réponse et permettez-moi de
faire au nom de votre groupe
trois propositions précises dans un
premier temps afin que les citoyens se
sentent réellement impliqués dans le
processus de construction européenne
il me semble indispensable de rendre
systématique la consultation des peuples
sur les traités essentiel deuxième point
il loupe par est aussi un disque
sable d'accroître les pouvoirs du
parlement européen par rapport à ceux de
la commission car actuellement ce qu'ils
prennent vraiment les décisions des
commissaires européens n'ont aucune
légitimité démocratique puisqu'il ne
sont élus par personne
troisième proposition nous pensons vous
y fait référence à l'évasion fiscale
qu'il est urgent d'avancer sur
l'harmonisation fiscale notamment
combien de temps encore allons-nous
accepter qu'un seul pays de l'union
européenne puissent bloquer les avancées
en matière de transparence et de
transmission automatique d informations
pour conclure j'espère sincèrement que
les élections du parlement européen le
25 mai prochain seront l'occasion
d'amener ces sujets au centre du débat
nous avons pour notre part bien
l'intention d'y contribuer très
activement je vous remercie
merci la parole à andré gattolin pour le
groupe écologiste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
fonctionnement démocratique de l'union
européenne laisse encore très fortement
à désirer c'est un fait indéniable
ce déficit démocratique est généralement
imputées aux institutions européennes et
les collègues qui m'ont précédé n'ont
d'ailleurs pas manqué de le rappeler
et ils n'ont pas tort mais sa
responsabilité incombe aussi à nos états
à nos gouvernements successifs à la
grande majorité des responsables
nationaux parlementaires inclus qu'on
aime ou qu'on l'a bord qu'on la rejoigne
ou qu'on la quitte l'europe est
désormais au corps de tous nos enjeux
politiques économiques ou
environnementaux comment considère-t-on
ces élections européennes comme scrutin
de seconde ou qu'ils n'iraient pas qu'on
s'y intéresse vraiment car au delà des
discours de façade lardé de belles
intentions nos pratiques des
contredisent de manière flagrante
je prendrai ici qu'un seul exemple mais
un exemple qui me paraît assez
emblématique à la fin du mois prochain
le sénat et l'assemblée nationale
suspendront leurs travaux durant cinq
semaines à l'occasion de la tenue des
élections municipales alors que le
parlement européen le parlement national
pardon vient enfin d'adopter une loi
contre le cumul des mandats ou
persistent ont accumulé des semaines de
suspension à l'occasion de ces élections
le scrutin municipal et d'un scrutin
très important pour la vie démocratique
je n'en disconviens évidemment pas mais
calendrier parlementaire de plus en plus
démentiel c'est sans aucune
commune mesure avec ce que ce reviendra
à l'occasion des prochaines élections
européennes
combien de temps de suspension de nos
travaux en amont de celle ci rien nada
ni laughing ni nt type hot à mich tas si
on veut parler en croate
pas une seule semaine par un misérable
jour dont nous permettre nous membres de
la représentation nationale et d'eau
fait citoyens européens de nous
impliquer pleinement dans cet enjeu
capital pour l'europe et pour notre pays
alors monsieur le ministre ma question
est simple quand va-t-on remédier à
cette aberration de notre agenda
à défaut de pouvoir changer
immédiatement ce calendrier injuste ne
pourrions nous pas en avril ou en mai
décidé de consacrer au moins une semaine
entière de nos travaux à l'europe et à
la dimension européenne
aujourd'hui partout présentes dans nos
choix et dans notre législation je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le ministre
oui monsieur le sénateur vous avez
raison nous vous rejoignons tous sur le
fait que les élections européennes c'est
vraiment un moment déterminant de la vie
démocratique européenne vis-à-vis d'une
institution qui compte de plus en plus
pour des décisions européennes mais
également sur l'impulsion législatives
sur des textes qui sont débattues voté
au sénat et à l'assemblée nationale
c'est d'ailleurs encore plus vrai depuis
que le traité de lisbonne indique que
les parlementaires européens éliront
très important le prochain président de
la commission européenne
ils le feront d'ailleurs sur la base
d'une proposition vous le savez du
conseil européen mais les chefs d'état
et de gouvernement 2 ou tenir compte
justement des équilibres politiques
issus de ce scrutin
et c'est pour cela qu'un certain nombre
de partis politiques ont d'ailleurs
d'ores et déjà choisi leur chef de file
pour cette campagne ce qui permettra de
mieux comprendre chez les électeurs
quelles sont les différences en quelque
sorte programmatique qui sont soumis à
leur vote
cette responsabilité à qu'elle vous
faites référence ne revient pas
seulement au seul gouvernement
je crois que chaque partie prenante
institutions européennes parti politique
doit agir à son niveau pour ce qui nous
concerne nous avons évidemment pris les
dispositions nécessaires pour garantir
un excellent déroulement du scrutin avec
une campagne d'information sur les
enjeux de ce scrutin
vous parlez des vacances parlementaires
vous savez que ce n'est pas une règle
c'est une tradition
elle appartient avant tout à chacun des
parlements de dire comment elle veut
aborder ce scrutin donc cette question
elle peut être répondu par plusieurs
orateurs par plusieurs initiatives mais
rien n'interdit par exemple au sénat ou
à l'assemblée nationale dans les
semaines qui précèdent de ce scrutin
d'avoir des sessions et yann sur
l'europe ce qui sera aussi une forme de
pédagogie à l'égard de nos concitoyens
donc j'invite finalement celles et ceux
qui ceux qui ont une idée ou un pouvoir
sur l'ordre du jour à inscrire pendant
quelques semaines des débats sur la
dimension européenne et d'ainsi éclairé
celles et ceux qui ont voté je l'espère
nombreux le 25 mai prochain
c'est bien mon cher collègue andré
gattolin merci beaucoup monsieur
ministre pour votre réponse et comme
c'est le président du sénat qui
aujourd'hui président cette saison je
crois qu'il n'a entendu le message
je crois plus généralement et là à
l'instigation des politiques mais du
gouvernement
c'est important à ce sujet il faut que
nous établissions une semaine par an au
minimum une semaine parlementaire
européenne parce que nous sommes un
certain nombre à la commission des
affaires européennes 36 officiellement
en réalité une petite douzaine a
réellement travaillées a passé notre
temps dans deux commissions à la fois
notre commission au fond est celle ci à
soutenir de relais il y a des tas de
collègues et on le voit quand il ya
débat européen est là aujourd'hui nous
sommes particulièrement nombreux en
partie parce que c'était des questions
d'actualité qui passent à la télévision
jeudi ces débats européens nous avons
parfois des vrais pub lacunes
d'explication entre nous et de
communication alors si les
parlementaires nationaux ne peuvent pas
être le relais non pas du discours des
institutions européennes mais d'un
discours sur l'europe
effectivement il faut pas s'étonner que
les citoyens participent de moins en
moins aux élections européennes je vous
remercie
merci je passe la parole à présent à
notre collègue joëlle garriaud-maylam
le groupe ump merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues en 2013 près de 13 millions de
citoyens de l'union européenne vivait
dans un autre état membre
c'est presque deux fois plus que dix ans
plus tôt c'est plus que la population de
certains états membres
l'essor des programmes d'échangés
universitaires comme erasmus et
l'ouverture des frontières dans l'espace
schengen ont favorisé ces migrations
intra européennes ces expatriés sont un
noyau de ce peuple européen appelée de
nos voeux et il pourrait être aussi le
fer de lance de l'émergence d'une
véritable citoyenneté européenne
mais la représentation politique tue pas
pour les élections européennes ils sont
largement condamné à voter pour nice
locales dans leur pays d'accueil
les europe à trier français peuvent
sinon optez pour voter dans la
circonscription d'ile-de-france réserver
des sièges au parlement européen
aux experts aux roues aux expatriés
j'aurais pourtant pas énorme vers la
fusion de listes transnationales telle
que rêvée par les pères fondateurs de
l'europe au lieu de rester arc bouté sur
la défense d'intérêts nationaux
ces eurodéputés défendre et une vision
politique globale du développement de
l'europe la france qui a historiquement
joue un rôle pionnier dans la
représentation de ces expatriés ne
pourrait-elle pas donner une impulsion
en ce sens
dans un premier temps ne pourrait-elle
pas décidé que les deux nouveaux sièges
au parlement européen alloué à la france
8 au traité de lisbonne soit réservé à
la représentation des expatriés un siège
pour alors représenter les français
d'europe l'autre les français du reste
du monde
c'est europe à trier soulève des
questions concrètes crucial un seul
exemple l'explosion nombre d'enfants nés
de national est différente s'est
accompagnée d'une hausse des divorces
les zetas abrite aujourd'hui derrière le
thriller souveraineté en matière de
droit de la famille est derrière des
mécanismes européens de reconnaissance
des décisions judiciaires
la commission des pétitions du parlement
européen a tenté de soulever ces
problèmes en vain
man encourager les instances européennes
a travaillé une résolution de ces
conflits familiaux et à la défense des
droits des enfants par exemple par le
biais de commissions entre
parlementaires nationaux ou par
l'instauration d'un défenseur des
enfants à l'échelle européenne une
génération d'européens ancré dans deux
ou trois cultures européennes
différentes est en train d'émerger
ne gâchons pas cette opportunité de
construire la citoyenneté européenne
merci monsieur le ministre pour la
réponse bien en deux minutes madame la
sénatrice je vais essayer d'apporter des
réponses premièrement pour vous dire que
nous avons même objectif que vous à
l'égard des français de l'étranger pour
leur dire ces élections européennes les
concernent effectivement directement et
nous avons en tout cas pas choisi la
solution d'une euro circonscriptions
pour les français de l'étranger
mais avec le même objectif nous avons
choisi une autre solution
les ressortissants français
effectivement résidant en dehors de
france pourront voter pour des listes
françaises puisque les français de
l'étranger seront représentés désormais
sur une liste ile-de-france et français
d'étrangers aux prochaines élections
européennes
c'est je crois un premier progrès par
rapport aux élections précédentes et
certaines familles je me permets de vous
dire politiques ont saisi la mesure de
ce progrès en retenant sur cette
circonscription des candidats des
français de l'étranger en bonne position
éligible pour le scrutin du 25 mai les
ressortissants français résidant sur le
territoire de l'union auront donc la
possibilité de voter soit sur des listes
locales soient sur la liste
ile-de-france et français de l'étranger
s'ils sont inscrits au consulat
je souhaite aussi qu' il y ait beaucoup
de gens qui aillent voter c'est pour
cela qu'il me semble que c'est une vraie
opportunité que l'élection des
consulaire le même jour soit organisé ce
sera donc une opportunité de voter deux
fois et on sait que on se déplacent plus
facilement lorsqu'il y a deux élections
le même jour sur le problématique des
couples binationaux
de plus en plus de nos citoyens sont
concernés on doit donc apporter une
attention particulière et vous le savez
dans le cadre d'une coopération
renforcée entre quatorze états membres
un règlement facilitant les procédures
de divorce entre époux de nationalité
différente adaptée en 2010
s'il applique avant france depuis 2013
jusqu'ici dépendant du droit de leur
résidence des couples binationaux
pourront dorénavant choisir la loi
applicable à leur divorce
je prends un exemple un couple franco
allemand installé depuis quelques années
en italie pourra donc choisir de
divorcer selon le droit français italien
ou allemand s'il choisit la loi le monde
un tribunal italien a piquera alors les
règles du droit allemand vous voyez y
compris dans ce type de législation dont
nous ne souhaitons pas qu'elle se
développe beaucoup parce que ça veut
dire qu'il ya beaucoup de divorces
nous essayons d'apporter des réponses
pragmatiques aux soucis de nos
concitoyens merci mes chers collègues
quelques secondes s'il vous plaît oui
merci monsieur le ministre
malheureusement ces réponses sont
insuffisantes et vous le savez il ya des
cas concrets qui sont extrêmement graves
qui travaille depuis des années en
particulier en matière de droit de la
famille et nous devons aller beaucoup
plus loin et aussi en matière de
citoyenneté européenne depuis 1992
depuis le traité de maastricht nous
entendons permanence que cette
citoyenneté européenne est une coquille
vide
nous entendons parler de déficit
démocratique alors qu'il y a des
solutions
et c'est vrai que pour les français de
l'étranger honnêtement la solution n'est
pas véritablement celle de voter sur des
listes nationales solution d'ailleurs
qui existait depuis 1979 qui avait été
supprimée relativement récemment et qui
ré et restituer mais avec eux deux
centres de vote
peu de possibilités de vin est pas de
possibilité de vote par correspondance
beaucoup d'expatriés très éloignées des
centres de vote et il n'est pas toujours
très gratifiant de voter pour une
élection locale dans un pays où l'on
n'est que de passage
j'ai où l'on ne connaît pas les
représentants d'où l'importance de
compléter le dispositif qui avait été
institué avec une représentation à la
fois au sénat à l'assemblée nationale
mais aussi au parlement européen
parce que c'est français de l'étranger
ne sont les vrais artistes
des leurs merci la parole à jean yves le
co pour le groupe socialiste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre chers collègues
l'europe c'est aujourd'hui le cadre
économique et social qui s'impose à tous
les européens les débats politiques
nationaux
lorsqu'ils sont ni trop simpliste
portent souvent sur la meilleure manière
de réorienter telle politique européenne
cela va de la politique monétaire à la
politique de la ville pour donner
quelques exemples
c'est pour cela que les élections
européennes de mai prochain seront
essentiels nous avons eu un débat sur le
partenariat transatlantique qui sera je
l'espère au coeur des élections pn mais
lorsque je dois faire quelle remarque
lorsque un budget qui est toujours la
traduction d'une politique est fait pour
ce qui concerne l'union européenne dans
un cadre pluriannuel qui ira jusqu'à
2015 et qu'il est validée avant même
l'élection des députés européens qui
siégeront en 2014 à 2019
n'y at il pas ici une confiscation de la
démocratie
deuxième observation il n'y a pas de
démocratie sans peuple
c'est pour cela que l'émergence
progressive de la citoyenneté européenne
est essentielle à la poursuite de la
construction européenne avoir la
nationalité d'un état membre c'est être
citoyen européen
comment réagir monsieur ministre
lorsqu'un état membre en l'occurrence
malte met en vente la citoyenneté
européenne
troisième remarque jusqu'il ya peu le
cadre de la construction européenne
c'est l union européenne depuis 2008
c'est pourtant entre les pays de la zone
euro que des initiatives ont été prises
pour corriger les défauts de l'union
monétaire qui aurait pu s'avérer
mortelle le mécanisme européen de
stabilité
le pacte budgétaire l'union bancaire ce
sont dans ce cadre c'est dans le cadre
de la zone euro que de nouvelles
harmonisation été mise en place
mais ces succès techniques sont aussi
des risques politiques
tant qu'il n'y aura pas un contrôle
démocratique directe sur ses
orientations qui sont aujourd'hui choisi
de manière intergouvernementale
monsieur le ministre comment assurer
l'orientation des choix budgétaires et
financiers des pays de la zone euro de
manière directe démocratique
comment avec des dispositions l'isi
est simple assurer la cohérence de ses
orientations avec le vote des européens
lors des élections au parlement européen
en mai prochain et qui concernera
l'ensemble de l'union européenne
je vous remercie très bien merci
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
oui monsieur le sénateur vous qui êtes
un spécialiste reconnu de ces questions
permettez moi d'apporter une ou deux
réponses l'idée de synchroniser
finalement les calendriers budgétaires
et politiques que vous suggérez peut
exercer une certaine séduction cela
effectivement ferait complètement sens
dans le cadre financier pluriannuel pour
qu'il soit finalement aligné sur plat
durée des mandats de la commission et du
parlement européen c'est d'ailleurs la
raison pour laquelle le traité prévoit
que le cadre financier doit être d'une
durée d'au moins cinq ans pourtant il
cette idée présente des difficultés
d'une part il faudrait il faut être
conscient par donc la négociation du
cadre financier pluriannuel
vous le savez c'est une procédure qui
est longue ainsi entre l'adoption de la
proposition de la commission
l accord définitif du conseil et du
parlement il peut s'écouler au moins
deux ans ça a été le cas récemment pour
peu que la commission ne prenne ses
fonctions que quelques mois après les
élections européennes comme ce fut le
cas la dernière fois alors cette
concordance des calendriers budgétaires
et politiques est très difficile
d'assurer dans la durée et d'autre part
un cadre financier réduit à 5 ans
pourrait affecter la bonne conduite de
certaines politiques européennes qui ont
besoin de durée qui repose sur une
programmation pluriannuelle
je pense en particulier à la politique
de cohésion sociale je pense aussi aux
politiques de développement rural
al'inverse incarnant un cadre financier
de 7 ans offre la possibilité à ce type
de politique de pouvoir produire
pleinement leurs effets mais je voudrais
vous rassurer
évidemment les nouveaux parlementaires
auront leur mot à dire sur le cadre
financier pluriannuel 2014-2020
puisqu'il était prévu explicitement une
clause de revoyure pour justement tenir
compte du fait qu'il aura de nouveaux
députés européens enfin sur la
légitimité démocratique de la zone euro
comme vous savez nous souhaitons qu'il y
ait des politiques plus approfondie plus
gray je vous le répète nous attendons du
nouveau parlement européen qu'il met en
place un pendant démocratique
c'est-à-dire une institution une
commission c'est allah au parlement de
le dire spécifique sur la zone euro pour
apporter la vie des parlementaires avant
que toute décision ne soit prise
c'est ce que demande la france rejoint
par l'allemagne
merci jean yves compte pour nous parce
que monsieur le président merci monsieur
le ministre sur la dernière question je
retiens la réponse que vous aviez fait
préalablement à mon collègue est votre
affirmation sur ce point je crois que ce
sera un élément utile et qui permettra
une lisibilité dans le contrôle
démocratique de la zone euro pour ce qui
est du budget européen je comprends bien
tout les avantages d'un budget qui
s'inscrit dans la durée
je sais aussi ce qu'il ya dans les
textes aujourd'hui dans les traités
toutefois si on veut vraiment donner aux
citoyens qui sont aujourd'hui perdu par
le l'absence hans de contrôle sur ce
type de choses il faut évoluer
peut-être pas sur ce cadre budgétaire la
met sur le prochain faire en sorte que
les traités évolué et que la pratique
surtout évolué des gouvernements et des
parlements nationaux et du parlement
européen de manière à skier concordance
et que ça puisse être fait de manière
plus beau plus facilement
compréhensibles pour l'ensemble des
citoyens jours merci mes chers collègues
nous avons fini avec cette séance de
questions cribles je vais suspendre la
séance 3 épisodes
voilà vous aidons pu suivre en direct la
séance de questions cribles des
questions cribles consacré au déficit
démocratique au sein de l'union
européenne on se retrouve dans quelques
instants
liberté égalité
en tunisie trois ans après la révolution
de janvier 2011 les droits des femmes
sont devenues un symbole et un enjeu
politique
la fiche à 5-0 jaune
dans un pays qui faisait figure
d'exception dans le monde arabe
ces droits sont aujourd'hui menacées des
femmes mais aussi des hommes se battent
pour les défendre tunisienne sous la
ligne de front samedi à 15h15 sur public
sénat